guys i just heard that twitter cfo is
talking about
paying their employees in bitcoin and
adding bitcoin to their balance sheet
so if they do this this is gonna be
insane for bitcoin because obviously
you've seen this week
tesla put 1.5 billion dollars into
bitcoin so
what we're seeing now is actual mass
adoption we're always talking about when
will that happen
but it's happening now real world
companies
major institutions are waking up and
picking bitcoin
instead of gold as their hedge against
inflation
as their store of value the world is
waking up and people can no longer
ignore bitcoin this is going to be
incredible not just
for bitcoin's price but for all of us
i'm excited